hey everyone Tom here watching the
Watchmen podcast back yet again you've
probably forgotten about us because I
mean to be honest I'd forgotten about
this [ __ ] series the last issue today
were doing issue 11 of Doomsday Clock
the last issue issue 10 that was May
29th so we've had like basically the
entire summer has come and gone in us
waiting for this you know if you are new
to the show we are going through started
off with Watchmen and now we kind of had
to felt we were obliged in some way to
go on to the sequel certainly regret the
decision
this has been an abhorrent series but
even fun to discuss and I discuss it
with deaf deaf how's it going hey guys
my head's completely done in with this
now Tom when will it end like it's been
two years of our lives this crazy
November 2017 yeah and it was supposed
to be a weekday yearly event like yeah
and it probably will finish in November
as well just by the way stuffs being
delayed actually just looking at the
cover now it says November 2019 Wow so
looks like they're gonna drag this one
out into 2020
yay it should never end if anything no
no I mean I just yeah I'm just
parentally baffled by this series really
and - - of you going into this I don't
remember much I was thinking today at
one eye only only read this a little
while ago for recording episode a finger
what I [ __ ] know about this story
what went down rush was there and people
got turned to glass and then thought
there's a novel Rorschach and there's
like this bug man who goes back into
flames and [ __ ] and I was like I was
like what the [ __ ] is this I was like
I'd tachyons basically uh I was kind of
you know just getting glimpse and stuff
thankfully this issue so much rehashing
even though it's the penultimate issue
it pretty much pretty much keeps you up
to date at least yeah definitely and it
doesn't feel like we've said this so
many times over the last six years but
it doesn't feel like a penultimate issue
it's very much sort of setting the stage
for things
and so yeah let's get into it let's get
into it so the cover is Batman grabbing
someone's hand to stop them from setting
off the launch but I don't really get
like this should be a threatening sort
of image you should be like I just got
it in the last second this is like when
James Bond when the timer ticks down to
one and he stops it you don't really get
that ramped up from from looking at it
it's very sort of pedestrian almost the
the cover it's difficult really get
excitement from this not only just
because of what's happening in it but
also just you know Gary Frank we do like
them but the way it's drawn it's just
very sort of there it's not like dynamic
it's just the guy you know get about a
turn a key and that man holding interest
I think that's the most exciting thing
is it no it's got a bit nice metaphor
really like we want some sort of
explosion and yeah John's is just
holding us back yet again and and
further delaying gratification and the
you know Watchmen covers in general gets
more Dave Gibbons than Gary Frank's work
over in a minimal sense where you're
just getting one object you know like
the photograph that the feature of this
issue or like I saw complex Vista they
have to scare and appreciate and this
does have t-tail but like you say it's
just like launch enabled ApS power you
just kind of has all the names of what
would be on this reactor core but I
really give a [ __ ] about them yeah and
there's a big reason in films when
something like this is happening that
they kind of cut around it and and kind
of focus more on the action itself
rather than someone just sitting at the
control panel and it's because it's
really really boring just watching
someone fiddle about on a control panel
so yet I don't know not a good way to
kick-start the issue personally for me
some people might love it I'm sure we'll
see on IGN later that they give it a 10
out of 10
yeah but yeah just very very basic for
me very sort of pedestrian I feel is the
word one of the worst covers I think
there's been there's been some okay ones
here and there there's not been any
fingers you know Yanik know
is a better version of this cover
actually in the issue and we do see
Batman sort of fighting with the
soldiers and it's it's just on the first
page after the batarangs been thrown on
the screen
send sparks everywhere and it's just
throwing these three people by the looks
of it at each other and that for me is a
far more interesting cover than what
will get with a Crichton and the key
yeah well yeah I'm not a comic book
artist but for me that's better than the
cover Batman looks awesome though I must
say yeah it's it's very that is I was
saying that the the cover isn't dynamic
it's just you know grabbing the wrist
whereas that is a dynamic image you've
got someone upside down falling into
someone what looks like a woman falling
against him Batman
you know he's like swiping down like
he's really throwing it you really do
get the motion from that image the Cape
sort of flapping in the air and that is
a very dynamic image and it completely
juxtaposed is Tom never gosh is the word
of the podcast the initial cover image
which is just someone holding a key yeah
yeah and unfortunately this could I
agree this would be a way better cover
it just couldn't be though it would go
against that watchman lineage where you
need something you know symbolically
heated and like an old-school 50s cover
this will be good on but um not really
for this and yeah I agree like the
people being hurled especially the third
guys look upside down like cat bowling
into them there is a lot of a fun action
there but um you know again it's just a
bombardment of history here like you
know learn about the president we
learned about that the gang wars and
golf are opting into chaos and then he
forgot about Rorschach's Journal I know
I did as well yeah yeah Alfred's just
sitting reading it just going from like
a really boring panel to a really
extreme panel back to a really boring
one of someone just reading a book and
Tom it this issue is all over the place
its jumps about so much
it just jumps from the perspective to
perspective I'm gonna go into it lay
hair cuz I've got quite a lot to talk
about but it's just all over the place
you're jumping from Batman - then Alfred
- then Lou Thesz on the street who say
you once do you want you only see what
you want to see you see what you want to
see is a note on the ground and they say
I see free stuff yeah yeah yeah bad
Langton and then you've also got on the
TV that they're robbing you've got
Nathaniel - sure and it's just joking
about and then so on the same page
you've got Alfred Lucas Nathaniel dusk
Batman and oz human diets and our
Zealand deities panel features multiple
screens as well yeah it's so much going
on at once and it's just way way too
overloaded and then from if that didn't
lose you Tom we then cut to wonder woman
fighting Giganta I think she's called
rightly this Tom put no Tom this book
you know I went fully marbled at this
point Tom you know I started off DC oh
yeah when fully Marvel these days Tom I
forgot all their names
I think it's gigantic like we said is
this guy Joker it's not Joker but it's
clearly Joker's face like come on the
Kree shirts the creeper yeah um who was
a Gotham radio host so they attack they
attack us
Jack Ryder Jack right oh that wasn't
maybe I haven't forgotten not everything
day night on but again it's jumping so
much from perspective to perspective
like you do you get the feeling that the
supervillains are taking over and that
the government don't really have any
option but to fight back with nuclear
weapons and I do get that it is a tale
of escalation
like if superheroes did exist and they
kept defeating that every single weapon
that normal people throughout them you
can see how countermeasures like this
would be put in place yeah even if the
humans were like ah this could
potentially kill us like well it's gonna
be worth it if we kill these superheroes
but it's so that message is just like
it's it's a back it's at the back of the
book
because the action is just running amok
here yeah and so we have Wonder Woman at
the UN and one of the things we love so
much about Watchmen were the more isms
of the irony being what's shown on
screen and what's the caption and you
just touched on earlier with the you see
what you want I see free stuff which is
so like a bane it kind of makes me but
yeah and then we have the bigger they
are the bigger they fall literally a big
person falling it's like what you're
doing John's there's no poetry or
subtlety there like you know it's as
galumphing as the image we see and it
just keeps going flit and flip and flip
and flip and you know to be fair the
later issues of Watchmen did kind of do
that because so many pot lines were
coming to a head but here I'm just
really not invested well yeah but even
with the watch I mean you know yeah and
it was five characters it was easy at
juggle you'd had them all set up at this
point no one's had like the the full
setup that they deserved like I don't
think it's all been sporadic throughout
I personally I think that this entire
book should have just been from Batman's
perspective the entire time right
because he's a detective so all of the
reveals and all of the secrets in the
main story all the revelations he can
unearth himself because he's a detective
he's also a human so he inhabits the you
know inhabits the world he can see
things from a ground level see why
things are escalating but he's also in
the world of superheroes as well so he
can view and interact with both sides of
the coin and I think the fact that we
just don't have is single in the writer
for the entire thing means that we don't
have a single narrative and it just
jumped all over the place like going
back to Watchmen Watchmen had five
characters this has about 15 and it's
also rare that they actually interact
with each other whereas Watchmen they
did in two was a history whatever as
well like yeah you would you would have
a Rorschach issue you'd have an aisle
issue but in those issues were
interconnected moments where
every character sort of got together and
you could see it from every issue sort
of built on that moment so the meeting
where all the watchmen come together and
the comedian famously lights up the map
and I say she'll be the last man on the
cinder you get that meeting from every
single perspective so that's an
important moment in the stories they get
from every single perspective this it's
got way more characters and there's not
that single one uniting moment like and
Watchmen has about ten of those where so
you can actually juggle more characters
because of it because we're familiar
with what we're seeing so because we've
seen it from another perspective where
is this you Chuck in like 15 character
but we're up to page four now we've had
Batman Alfred
Lou Thesz Wonder Woman Nathaniel Dirt's
Wonder Woman you can black Adam then
pops up then general Lane who's Lois
Lane's father I did appreciate seeing
him but it's it's too much going on and
it's so disconnected that it's difficult
to invest or care about any of it
because nothing's really gripping here
it's it's all underdeveloped
yeah and it's recap recap recap even the
stuff we have in the war room we've you
know this Superman theory and all these
kind of ideas have been explored before
and then we're going back to the Hall of
Justice and Putin's mentioned and we get
the shot of Superman before everyone
became glass or something like that and
then there was fire Stovall guy yeah it
just offers up stuff and stuff and so I
don't even remember Lois and Lex getting
together but now they're exploring the
plot like yeah and like the main
questions that pull people into this
they've not really been touched upon
like what what actually happened to the
comedian I they never explained why I
ended up where he was and what he's been
doing for the last 35 years like the the
books just not providing the answers
that you want and it's setting up things
that you don't really care about like
the other week I remembered that DC in
rebirth issue one set of three Joker's
so they had a big reveal where it was
like they're through there is actually
three Joker's that was like three years
ago
not being mentioned again I remember Tom
I was in Spain at the time and the
headlines were Joker's identity he
finally revealed in rebirth 1 and I was
abroad and I still thought you know what
I'm gonna have to get a DC app on my
phone I'm gonna have to read this and
find out what the hell's going on
my son read it and there was no answers
and in that time from that happening
I've went completely against DC now to
the point that I'm just a Marvel fan boy
it is nichelle and yeah it's just they
just dropping the ball everything
they've set up all the promises then
then answering I want answers to these
questions and what happened to the
comedian Lindelof yeah there's no
cohesion because of it and and then we
cut to Ozymandias after we've seen
Superman kind of on a bed yeah ain't
captured and honestly Tom flicking
through this and just seeing all of the
different people that are introduced
it's there's so many five panels in a
row where it's the same character no no
and this is where the you know the Dave
Gibbons grid can work against you like
if you just chop and stuff in there and
just feel so scattershot and you know
there's a few ideas for out this issue
ideas they're more just like little
stylistic things that they put into the
story that I do appreciate like I like
the fact that if superheroes were going
mental
and there was crazy weather predicted
that the wet the weather map behind the
weather God would look completely absurd
will you get to see that yeah that's
nice but about it and I like the
planet's krypton restaurant that we see
later as well I don't know if that's
been done before but that was quite cute
now what how I would have done this Tom
I tell you what I should be the bloody
CEO of DC Comics to tell you that I
would've just had a double page spread
with Ozymandias standing watching the TV
screens as we see and I would have just
had on all of those TV screens those
panels and a little speech bubble coming
off saying what's in it and just that
spread across two pages so you would
really get the feeling that you
everything's sounding off in one frame
you would get the feeling that it's
frantic but as a reader you can digest
it where is this Tom it's all over the
place
and I'll tell you what if I joined give
it a turn our turn yeah yeah it blocking
them on YouTube I'm verified now Tom and
I tell you what I will not of them doing
that it's astonishingly gauche really
and the fact that Superman's logo turns
up on the cracked screen like yeah
[ __ ] hell
John's you thought you were such a
genius putting this together like you
know this is just it's a and Aziz in
Arkham right I've got no idea I kind of
got Arkham vibes but I don't know if he
might be here and those guys are in
prison cells yeah might be so I don't
know how he got access to all these
screens and this kind of suite over
there and then we have San girl who's
here for something isn't from the future
but can't read his mind machinae in one
of those stories she if read Reggie
didn't she or something right okay well
Tom I've got a spoiler fear she's
completely useless okay and she gets
killed off pretty pretty most lessly in
it book with there and there was no real
point here the entire time so that's why
now interesting bit though Tom that I
did quite enjoy lex luthor says he's
been tracking the photo of john
throughout time and it's been a heavy
part that dr. Manhattan has okay okay
don't Moines this part and I agree I did
reread this guy I kind of tried to try
to understand this I did yeah I didn't
you know I didn't get it either
yeah yeah why it's duplicated well yeah
no but but why when people cross
dimensions do they leave useful
souvenirs of themselves
yeah where does that happen yeah no no
but but like I mean that purely happens
for plot but that just defies all logic
to me and that just feels because and
how did Lex originally stumble upon the
photograph or know that it had powers
did he just discover two versions by
chance go through these job lots and
decide there was a time warp connection
like yeah exactly you would surely just
think like oh maybe in all these photos
look alike maybe they're just someone to
develop like yeah we can do that
yeah I mean they never signed on the
back so maybe but still it's just like
then they do cut to lexing and Kid Flash
in rebirth issue one getting cold that
will oh yeah exactly why was he actually
there that's a longer look why was it
just walking in a bush yeah
he says he's tracking abnormal chronal
energy spikes why was he doing that
why was Lex Luthor he's normally since
he was a boy that that's his explanation
apparently yeah yeah I don't know all
the time oh man but the flashes were not
the source anomalous tracking and the
fact that the photo was there and like
later in the back book in the back
matter and we see the photo it's quite
well realized yes don't in it well
that's pouch looks really cool actually
looks really really cool and then we
also see a photo of like that famous
cover of the two flashes descending so
it's like mini speed camera for like
parallel universe shifting that just
shows you I really hate that I really
hate it yeah it's just I don't
understand at Tom and I don't agree hate
lightly art though like that dr.
manhattan's just going through time just
dropping photos everywhere but what does
it mean why like what's happening what
is going on you know what would have
been better right if they'd started off
the issue one just in the DC Universe
Lex Luthor finds that photograph yeah
that was an issue one or e4e or he finds
it he goes mental you don't know why and
it's because he's been looking for that
this final one or something and it means
everything and it's interesting actually
because the photo we see itself maybe is
just a mistake I'm not sure isn't quite
like the photo in Watchmen it's like the
dog is a slightly different light like
there's there's part of the photo that's
here that there isn't there on Mars
because I wasn't even obviously I know
it travels with John so John did you
like pick the foe up in Mars I think he
might have done but still it doesn't
really make any sense but I guess the
whole reason - you've pictured up to me
I keep dropping it everywhere
constantly duplicate that's what I don't
get I don't know I died I think I think
what it's saying there is because Louis
to say you're saying the photos
traveling retirement he's saying not the
foes so I guess technically doesn't
travel through time he sort of
experience everything at once so I guess
cuz the folk like the photos unlike him
then and they experience everything at
once I guess okay it's but it's like I
just want a good plot like we've watched
from we never grappled with any of this
because it was just laid out beautifully
and the budget cohered but this is just
you didn't have to explain the times to
freely in what Hammond was oh is that
wasn't the plot no but it was really
well realized as well like Manhattan
would mean to get your teeth into Robins
be baffled by but here just not and it's
given a few pages and it is kind of
interesting we both said we reread it
and I don't dislike the idea but I just
don't think that the selling of it's
very well done yeah and this is probably
the thing that we spend the most time on
in the book and maybe that's why I liked
it the most you know maybe if they'd
have done something else for this long
we would have liked it as as much but
this is it this is the highlight of
every issue yet Tom it's all downhill
from here so enjoy a bad state and
Superman being accosted by the US
government
yeah which is stupid yeah we've seen in
Man of Steel and he was just he did it
to be polite
Tommy wore the handcuffs but he was just
being polite yeah because as soon as he
couldn't be bothered we're and then we
snap them off he is I suppose he is
saying I don't want any trouble
lower your weapons please which yeah
fair enough but you wouldn't pull a gun
on Superman here no why is being
arrested again how could the Russia
thing what was that about what issue was
that how long ago was that what year was
that that was a long that was a while
ago maybe that was probably like two or
three issues ago the Red Square showdown
with Posner and although it's like 10
years yeah yeah cuz at least like on the
old Marvel things you get like Stanley
put a little asterisk like issue 450
deal readers and [ __ ] but he don't
really true blues and you don't really
get that the stop doing that
no they have stopped doing that and oh
okay you didn't stop stop doing think
bubbles as well Tom I got rid of them
I don't I don't quit like Aziz got a lot
of screen setup and this is obviously a
reference to Karnak and whatever I don't
know why he's got the final dusk playing
on the wall though because we see it
yeah was that not the e-field or some
does he not know that it was okoma
and no film ends with like someone
talking on screen it's not who lose it's
how you play the game it's like these
just mealy-mouthed aphorisms why does
this film keep getting shown on TV as
well Tom Waits Carver's 70 years old
I know it must have some sort of
dramatic import in the same way that
black freighter did but yeah oh my god
no no no no no not comparable at all
Aziz here Aziz looking forward to me in
Superman and again talking about wasted
pages why we getting alpha with the
pancakes I was scouring these phones
nine panels for some sort of meaning a
guy standing on a you know black and
white tiles and it's cool to see the
kitchen of the manor bar got the
Rorschach mask in it it would have been
nicer if when he says I've got something
for you to eat and he just brought the
pangs Oh harm anybody made them probably
seeing him make them yeah our throats
got too much time on his hand I wonder
why he bloody does he just sits about
reading all the time and making pancake
stack people that aren't even Bruce
Wayne does he know Bruce Wayne's in
Russia is he not meant to be sat in the
back hey about the computer yeah yeah
yeah what sir I love that in Scott
Snyder books he always has them in
Batman ones whenever a Trump's up
Alfred always a spot sir nobody meet
relax Isabella Hammond
sounded better in my head that Tom book
even is coronet so me reading Batman by
Scott Snyder
we get a dream sequence yeah issue 11
isn't it helped to build on the plot and
helped of further in so many ways
put it in that issue 11 and it's like
yeah his dad burns alloys dad immolate
when he sees Walters I do get it like
and again we get more seeing something
in the fire which we've already had with
the moths going like series series issue
free or for like mmhmm yeah sucks it
really does and it's like I don't know
like I like when the Rorschach symbol
comes up the seat you'll we see the
Rorschach inkblots and different things
I always called on gonna be wrong but
here it's just a bit the wings and the
fire and the face and and then Alfred
offering pancakes again like Alfred's
whole journey is just pointless yeah I
know it's why is he here Tom you know
you look if you're looking for stuff to
cook he looks really creepy as well and
that top right photo and reaching in his
bag like hey I got something for you
homeless man badly badly done and you
know the pancakes hit the floor isn't
that sweet the narration says as well
and now we get back to these two where
the [ __ ] are these guys beard yeah I
know I was I did actually have in my
notes you know when I was asking about
the comedian before I had to take them
out but I was gonna ask where the hell
have the mime and marionette been and
what was their point we do kind of get
like an answer to it but mmm Thomas
fulfill in one no really convoluted
incredibly so yeah like almost reads
like a like a parody or something like
it just baffles any object who is the
main character in this story its Alfred
it might be the pancakes Loki because
they're they feature on a cover but but
yeah there's no one to kind of put your
how no no no at all it's got Star Wars
Episode one fun of Menace syndrome why
this it's not a main character and no
one's got any idea what's going on how
we do learn no sorry no no go ahead man
we do learn about the child being
adopted by so expecting like hell yeah
we're on it yeah don't mind that nice
yeah but is it enough to say that
it's supposed to show that dr. Manhattan
still cares about things because he
could have killed the kid but he saw
that it would make yeah them happy so
yeah maybe he still cares about thing
he's back he's got he's underpants on
that time I've just noticed way he's
talking in the Miami marina did he have
his dick out the first time I don't
think so no deceive got a big thing
against dick stone there cuz the had
that issue with Batman's dick in they
just got rid of it Kevin Smith didn't
Batman piss himself or something as well
oh that was taught I tell you what Tom
their internet overreacted it was Batman
crouching behind the thing right and
there was a lot of heat and he pissed
himself a nice soup that wasn't scared
or anything in there
well Kevin Smith yeah the reason he said
he did it was because firefighters
sometimes when they go into burning
buildings just the heat you know like
when you get in the shower yeah just the
heat it makes you want to have a piss so
he said that he's been speaking to
firefighters and they went in the
burning building and they the the heat
sometimes makes them have a piss in
their suit so you just said I'll just
put on a Batman story cuz the heat tell
you what the internet did not like it oh
god no do not try to change anything
because the Internet will not like it
what you mean as a black Captain America
Oh human James Bond's a woman now is he
do not tell them that Tom do you mean
constant this video
I I mean the kid doesn't need to say hi
mom over really no but I guess it's a
way to cut to marionettes splat face
again the blood underneath is like yeah
is it like a is it a satisfying
revelation like this was teased to
nothing issue three or four or whenever
it was five years and we were we were
expecting like something from this child
weren't we like oh
marionette she's only going with us
human dies because she's gonna find out
who I wear a kitties and what was the
point of a kid and ditto did am I
remembering this right did Rorschach
show her a picture of the kid and that's
what's got it wrong like that yeah yeah
so Ozzy said like I know where the
kiddies or something like that
yeah so the payoff to that entire
storyline is a one panel box
mm-hm with don't know yet they keep like
me might stop Superman and dr. Manhattan
and I just get in the middle of it so
that would be great that that we go
but we don't get that we get more and
more but that's the story I want to see
you Tom I for some reason we're getting
all this exposition shoveled down off
roads like so much of it
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah I'm risking the
video getting do you monetize here Tom
but it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
it really is it really is and it's just
kind of all these plans that get brought
up and broker and you know get a big
splash panel of all these DC heroes
because why not
we're all like perspectives really weird
and them like Batman's heads really
massive but yeah it was the DC Universe
Tom got a massive Batman head you've got
a tiny Nightwing you've got a massive
Greenland and you've got the fish he's
kind of in the background but then
there's no more ocean in the right side
and I mean wide some of these people
have made it in this cover though like
you've got him scot-free and Barda as
well they're taking up quite a big
school I tell you what no one knows who
the hell they are
I've got no clue and then who's discount
I am man kind of at the bottom as well
that's got free there that's got for it
lead yeah guy it's damn apocalypse guy
he's a new guards guy that's two years
no eyes here but where why Superman not
in this panel he's the big I tell you
what Tom he's meant to be what it's all
building the wall yeah yeah it should
have Superman front and center of that
panel he was yeah and I think
earlier in the last issue that kind of
his world the DC Universe is the beating
Center and Superman yeah it was kind of
the gold light there so yeah again not
quite sure why this decision was made
really waste yeah and again a lot of
things could have been told a lot lot
quicker yeah and we just get loads of
just really lame like Ozzy discovering
that the Superman Theory was partially
true and he's at the desk in the [ __ ]
West Wing and it's like always used to
foil their that just told you what you
needed to know how come via it was like
a photograph that appears after you walk
through space like yes when you when
someone hacks the computer in the log on
it and the first thing that comes up
it's like the evil master plan is never
good kind of okay they do it in Watchmen
to be fair when Dan breaks into Ozzy's
computer with the ramasees thing but
that's a bit different that's like a
kind of CEO compared to a head of state
like you know yeah
even then I didn't really think it was
that good Tom to be honest with you no I
don't think watchman's this perfect
story that everyone says but you know
there's a little bit there that I would
say that's not very good yeah yeah sure
rest of it though good boy if I make a
criticism not very good Tom but Tom were
finally getting to the big plan here so
I'm gonna try and explain what I took it
as he came to the fight
Ozymandias or Ozymandias you know what
you won write in the comments below but
don't put anything don't put anything in
the comments that makes it look like
you're indicating how to pronounce it
just write it out and so either
Ozymandias Ozymandias he came to the DC
Universe and saw that it was a
schizophrenic Society one of full of
hope and at the same time despair he
wanted to make it hit rock bottom to
change even though that plan didn't
really work in the Washington universe
so why would hit but he's been setting
up all of the events so that Superman
will fight dr. Manhattan and that the
revolution of supervillains will tear
the world apart and then the world will
have to recover from that yeah so is
that right that seems about right yeah
okay so Ozymandias or Ozymandias right
in the comments below is the true hero
in all the
this pretty much it is he what's this
about this two years we've been working
on cancer I think but then didn't ya
hurry don't know Tom no [ __ ] those and
it's just you know I don't know this
would have been great this could have
been great even though I never want
except that I'm kind of this is karmic
retribution I think I'm pretty sure Alan
Moore put a snake curse on this when it
was announced and it just being doomed
to this narrative dross because yeah the
supervillains for some reason assault
the white house and black Adams there
and there's some sort of rawrrr faceoff
and then Saturn girl gets very um she
get snapped away it seems yeah what
happens with her soul she tends to dust
doesn't she like like Thanos now thinks
because she's the future and she's
traveled back because he does say to
like Greenland to know whether you're
the past you'll survive so maybe he's
irrevocably changed to me but um maybe
this is why this was a delayed slightly
because it is [ __ ] ripping off
infinity war like I know this sort of
thing has been done before but it's so
reminiscent yeah definitely well d'art
there's some other ways that they could
have done it from just that turning it
dust which my grandma actually pointed
out to me and was ashes to ashes dust to
dust
which I never picked up on but you know
I can see where I get me comic book
insight from Tom and yes so they could
it another way he could have basically
what I would have done Tom as head of DC
CEO I would have I would have had aa
seaman Dyess you you cut to him talking
to her in the cell she's looking back
then you cut to him like explaining his
whole plan and at the end he says but
you don't even exist anymore because you
from another timeline you cut back to
the cell that he was talking to she's
not perimortem
you'd only is show the Dustin yet is
gone
oh I'm at DC CEO now I've heard that you
have to kill the DC CEO to become the DC
CEO so I don't want to do that no am I
the boss now
right in the comments below and you know
like the fact that you can see time is
so amazing that you can say like Oh in
seven hundred years this happened Orion
in two million seconds or something
counting down is not interesting going
from 5 - 4 - 3 - 2 - 1 which I know is
building height whatever burn all these
images all these stories Reggie in the
pod or with the Rorschach's whale in the
reflection and all this stuff I mean
finally at the time dr. Manhattan
wouldn't he wouldn't count down never
that just doesn't seem right you just
wouldn't count down you know we end with
this final countdown then I mean that is
a panel that couldn't sell a million
books they're at the top of the final
page why is it why is it just that panel
Tom they should have done full-page and
i'm truman he's going to stick out
though he does a good but but yeah
you're totally right yeah they should
have been like splash see like rather
than that [ __ ] DC to blue we got
earlier like yes tableau that was just
yet that was that was forgettable and
this kind of um three panel three panel
structure that ends it reminded me a
little bit of its to start the second
issue of watchmen eddie can be comedians
funeral and it kind of has Aussie Dan
and dr. Manhattan are looking on and I
believe the Bible verse is that a red
kind of summer page the characters
brilliantly and stuff like that yeah but
here we have it is time it's time like
you know that that's as much word play
wizardry is gonna get [ __ ] ' mm-hmm
yeah it's not the best time and you know
what the I don't like the way they
panels are crammed together
I'm sure Watchmen when it got towards
the the final thing the page is the the
panel size has got bigger so when it was
the when this the squid attack I'm sure
a lot of that was full-sized pages or
taking up quite a lot and they did it in
The Death of Superman
and so basically the longer that the
death of Superman goes on for in the
comics the big air it spreads across the
page so it starts off initially in you
know very small panels and then as the
fight goes on it gets bigger and bigger
across the page so the the panels break
down and it basically turns into you
that image at the top where it's just
across the three grid and I feel like
they should have done that but they're
not on and they've kind of ruined it
okay he's that clock it's his time it
was shown in this issue and I don't know
the place by that and it's like it's not
as deep as you think John's pretty much
everything in the world has circle so
yeah roaring like comparisons and
juxtapositions between the two is yeah
pretty name really and we get the Aussie
symbol to end so these fruity sort of
gods to us and I've been going
throughout the story um you know or at
least two of them are coming to a head
and having a Superman and it ends on me
and with the James Joyce quote so the
time is why have there been format and
tonight this Tom where it's like a strip
along the bottom yeah that is weird it's
significant that was never like that in
Warren
sucks it does it doesn't look as good
does it it's like a little kind of
whimsy sliver at the right so so yeah
lifelong mistake is the name of the
issue I'm not afraid to make a mistake
even a great mistake a lifelong mistake
and perhaps as long as eternity - so
James Joyce portrait the irises young
man one of his founding buildings Romans
and again dear listeners you know we are
not going from the Moore School of four
where the twist or sting of the quote is
the title and the supplementary stuff
beforehand really reinforces that idea
no I mean the meaning of this is kind of
OT owes a lifelong mistake it could have
been anything
really yeah what do you make the final
quote don't ya doesn't reinforce
anything whereas you know Watchmen as
you said it all kind of builds up and
then it's summed up perfectly a nice
quote at the end where's this it just
and then at the end of you mentioned
there is the back page material I'm
crazy about the little baggies of the
photos in he's really calling it do it
Tom how did
draw it looks great looks [ __ ] great
it looks that you mean it's real and
everything
the lexcorp's symbols cool and yeah we
learn about these photos and just for me
as kind of someone who appreciates the
little details in fiction and stuff I
like the idea where these photos were
found and where they were part and story
yeah and I'm sure a lot of the
references one was found in a field in
Smallville for example and in Arkham
Asylum and you know I'm sure there's
references I don't get like about
trainwreck outside Gotham I'm sure that
references like some sort of origin of
some character or whatever so we get to
see all these different images across
and I mean this picture essentially was
the catalyst for so much of the story
it's a shame that it's detailed it is a
garbled way really yeah and don't really
get what it means and you know I still
don't quite understand it maybe they
were an issue
pull it off Tom might do it but they've
also got a close about 70 different
stories at the same time yeah we'll see
it's the endgame has been absolutely
abysmal really I mean I know that's
probably the hardest part writing
anything but just none of these threads
are linking there's no there's no
through narrative it's never enough to
it there's no real courage it's just
kind of wallowing and yeah despise this
issue I really did well
so why is it out of 10 maybe this is the
worst issue Loki just because there was
very little new I'll probably give it
like 0.5 I think Wow so quite a zero
point five out of ten I don't know where
to go with this because I certainly I
would seem like okay one all right it's
not the worst one that you've read oh
people you know what Tom it looks like
people are finally turning against
Doomsday Clock because fortress of
solitude are going with the headline
this week Doomsday Clock 11 let's call
this what it is a mistake Wow yeah so
finally Tom been saying it
we've been watching people praised a
universe
and they've been I know and the quote
from this article I'm gonna take is a
mistake unafraid like this series in
general but still a mistake got three
point five Tom they reviewed some that
was if you like what long-winded
overstuffed exposition then you'll love
this story line two out of five all work
of five out of five which I think it's
fine tom guess what RG anybody giving it
no they've not given they do that a
perfect score
no and hey Alton hey that's that's
that's giving yeah well you can't spell
ignorant without IGN Tom Bakk the more
time passes the less it seems to matter
what lasting impact Doomsday Clock may
or may not have on DC comic books
continuity so why is that why is that an
eight it didn't you say it's throwaway
it doesn't matter it's crap verdict IGN
in terms of overall execution Doomsday
Clock eleven doesn't quite measure up to
many previous chapters of the series the
first half of the book jumps around too
freely and never lingers in any place
for more than a panel or two which we
said but luckily this issue finds a
clearer sense of focus as it moves along
eventually setting up a tense exciting
final issue and a long-awaited
confrontation between two all-powerful
heroes now the long wait for the final
issue begins eight out of ten Doomsday
Clock 11 is messy but still thrilling
and it sets up an epic final chapter
IGN don't go anywhere else please
because our channels dying you know
adventures in poor taste calm 4.5 out of
10 mm so yeah it finally does seem like
nice nice no not that makes donations
but the the Internet as a whole I mean
if you oh yeah I mean it is called a
lifelong mistaken at the issue which
sums up I think it does
it does perfectly yeah I mean how long
you know that is like the pun that you
used with the headline isn't it like
Doomsday Clock a lifelong mistake no
really yeah no really no we aren't
joking I know we give it 10 out of 10
every other issue but we'll finally
realize it's not worth it
sorry guys so yeah that's kinda that's
kind of here yeah overstuffed lethargic
I I'm eager to read the final issue I've
got I think you'll probably be a bumper
issue surely that they can't represent
surely and you feel like they have to do
as well just for how long this went on
for like Tom it's taken them as long to
write this as it took to make infinity
war and Avengers end game films no films
take two years to make from script into
shooting to CGI to editing release
marking strategies it's baffling that
it's taken two years it's just the time
of my life
yeah so hopefully it's good next time
well you know it's been fun to rip it
apart and I'm sure the rampage won't
stop on the final issue people go back
and listen to all our takes prior of
this and Watchmen yeah and other comics
and you know obviously deaths channel as
well you subscribe yeah yeah please
subscribe over there like yes I know
this probably won't get you know the
heft of your followers but if you've
enjoyed this maybe there's your first
time hearing it maybe you loved it and
you're like oh they're gonna explain it
a bit and know this because Aggie
British just goes mental on it so yeah
still always fun to talk comics with you
bro I guess that's about it really you
know we'll be back whenever this comes
out probably 2020 see you guys next year
it was on average gauge I think it was
like I think he was ever been monthly I
think it was like boy no no instantly
they try to do it yeah
but yeah guys just make sure that you
keep refreshing your subscription feed
every half hour until it pops up which
you know it will how good would it be if
they just canceled the series it will be
amazing
the watchman TV show comes out soon
actually it's on next month I mean no
it's November
yeah November but this is completely
killed my like interest in it to be
honest but you might be amazing but this
is just I don't really care that much
I'm not I'm not in the mood for another
like watchman inspired thing like I'm
just yeah if it's over the original nada
like you know I've been down this road
before but um yeah follow me at Bauer at
resume at Metallica pod if you want some
bear upon without like a podcasts
subscribe to death everyone for
subscriber night as well I can't believe
I start off at like 1000 subscribers
with this and then we're on 112 thousand
Adam alright so thank you everyone I
know it wasn't for this show it was for
the bloody spider-man news but thank you
for checking it out yeah yeah yeah no
definitely man and I'm looking forward
to the next one
yes say a good night from me even though
you always send me whenever I say it's
Doomsday Clock you go [ __ ] sake looking
forward to it keep that energy up for
the next two months tone-deaf this has
been great man it's a good night from me
good night from Queen